this is turned bad this has gone really  bad well that's a randomizer  yeah it had to be played I mean it would  go bad it had to be played on practical  terms yeah yeah but it's not good  it's still not good but yeah it  it's like one of those moves that is  white has to change the nature of the  position they're covering the A6  yeah it's that's a good move around now  92  that's resigns that's resigned is that's  got to be it just picking up wow wow but  I mean how dramatic it was look at this  at this computer  miss incredible Rook D1 idea and after  Queen takes it to Rook da Check and uh  you are winning  apparently you're winning yeah King F7  G8 Queen  and King F6 Loop D6 leads to to  Checkmate well I mean this would have  been incredible but I mean with few  seconds on the clock he just imposed